[Music]
theta I lose item stay not Canon ROM
Duke who is Marlene it's not it's minyak
Julia 30th back that was fun you guys
should try that sometime Julia I don't
know why I couldn't get July right it
always came out something like Julia
I mean 30th came out something almost
perfect but July I couldn't do and I
meant July July 30th good morning John
it's Monday July 30th and you know what
that means
it means I have to pay rent that
probably wasn't as exciting as you
thought it was going to be was it but
wait it actually is exciting it's
exciting because for those of you who
don't know John and I have been recently
discussing the fact that my house the
one that I live in is for sale upon
someone buying it they could conceivably
kick me out because I have a month month
lease I really didn't want to get kicked
out of my house and the new owner says
that she is happy to keep us as tenants
just so paying rent is for once a really
exciting and happy thing because means
means that I have a place to sleep at
night that is the pretty much the only
really exciting part of paying rent but
there's another reason why it's exciting
that it's Monday because I'm doing a
video Monday it means in my next video
it's on a Wednesday which means that
it's going to be a song that seems like
I came up really quick yeah I'm
concentrating a lot on Accio Deathly
Hollows you know checking out the video
responses reading the comments trying to
respond to all the messages sorry if I
haven't responded to you yet I will I
promise but uh how to come up with
another song for two days from now check
out this also nerdfighting crest let me
zoom my zoom it's who created
nerdfighters John I don't really know
how the songwriting process works for me
but luckily I had too many cokes last
night and while I was laying in bed at 3
o'clock in the morning some great lyrics
started to occur to me because I was
afraid of going to sleep and forgetting
the lyrics I got up and I walked into
the living room and I grabbed a pen and
then I grabbed this little pad of paper
that I remembered was hiding underneath
the phone so I grabbed it and I looked
at it and there on the little pad of
paper
or song lyrics song lyrics in my
handwriting on the same pad of paper
that I don't know if how long has been
hiding under that phone apparently I had
remembered that same pad of paper while
hoping not to forget song lyrics and I
had written them down and then instead
of you know losing the lyrics forever
I just forgot that I had written them
down I don't remember ever having
thought of these song lyrics nor do I
remember ever writing them down but here
they are and I don't know what the tune
is it says you look so good
I want to sprinkle you on my food if I
could I would eat you like a
five-year-old eat glue okay apparently I
thought that was really like worth
getting up out of bed and writing down
and then promptly forgetting maybe those
lyrics will find their way into a song
someday but that's probably not the one
I'm gonna do one Wednesday to people
who've been given the ideas for what to
write songs about that is actually kind
of helpful it actually wasn't my idea to
write a song about Harry Potter last
time that was somebody in the comments
or in the forum I don't remember but
thank you so much to whoever it was that
suggested that first anyway thanks to
coca-cola classic for helping me write
songs and keeping me up until five
o'clock in the morning nonetheless I
think I'll actually have the song ready
on Wednesday hooray John I'm looking
forward to seeing you tomorrow